I just want to understand. Okay. What's
the So what's the question so I can help
you? My My question is regarding Islam.
Um
there's a lot of people that I work with
in the military and they say they say
there is You know, they they always talk
about Islam and
although I understand like I'm in a
place where religion shouldn't be
discussed, I don't necessarily care. You
know, like to me it's like if you ask
me, I'm going to tell you. Um
and I'm I will stand on what I believe
in.
All right. But my my concern is more of
a
I'm not somebody who reads the Quran.
What I know about the Quran is based on,
let's say, articles that I just started
reading the true way or um
let's say things here says
as opposed to me actually reading. And
the reason why I've never read it is
because I came from um I was Pentecost
and certain things like that we are
learn or we are taught that they bring
curses into your life, so you shouldn't
be reading certain things.
Again, ignorance. At least I think it's
ignorance. So my thing is just like
should I take the leap of faith and just
get me a Quran and start reading these
things so that I can understand like No,
but
>> what's the way that they're thinking?
No, because you're not grounded
and strong enough
in your own journey and understanding
for you to then pick up the Quran and
study it because to read the Quran
when you don't have a strong foundation
in your own faith tradition or in the
scriptures
only invites confusion. It's not so much
Satan or demons. Of course, they play a
role.
It's just that you're not grounded.
You're not strong. You're not solid yet.
And that's another thing. You don't go
to Muslims and tell them this is what
Islam is cuz they're going to ask you,
"Have you read the Quran?" No.
Uh then how do you know what the Quran
teaches? You're speaking out of
ignorance
and you're being prejudiced. So, what
you can do is, "Hey, I read that this is
what the Quran says. Can you check it
and see?"
Not, "Hey, this is what Muslims teach."
If a Muslim comes and tells you this is
what Christians believe and he doesn't
have a clue what the Bible teaches as
your microphone kills me in my ears.
I'm sorry. Help me, Lord.
Torture. I know you want to purge me and
make me patient.
Then, you'd be offended if a Muslim
tells you this is what Christians
believe and they don't believe that cuz
a Muslim is only going by hearsay.
Right?
>> Listen. Yes.
So, why would you
start studying the Quran when you're not
grounded in your own faith tradition?
You're not really
well-versed
in the core doctrines of the Christian
faith.
And so, that can create confusion.
Reading a book and then
not understanding the context of the
Quran cuz the Quran, you can't just read
it without knowing the historical
background
as asserted by Islamic tradition. What
do I mean?
The Quran consists of two different
periods in Muhammad's life
where certain chapters were composed
during one period of his life
and other chapters were composed in
another period of his life in two
different cities.
For the first
from 610 to 622 623, first 13 years,
Muhammad preached in Mecca in Saudi
Arabia according to the Muslim
tradition.
And so, there are chapters that are said
to be from that period. Their tone,
their message completely different from
then the second period of his life where
he migrated to Medina, which is north,
which is in Arabia
for the last
10 years of his life, those chapters
take on a different tone and a message.
Since the Quran is not written
chronologically,
you won't know what chapter was composed
when,
and you won't be able to tell that the
message changed depending on Muhammad's
dominance or lack thereof.
That's a lot.
You understand?
Well, yeah, that's why I said that's a
lot. Like, yeah, I shouldn't
At least I That's why I don't I don't
try to like
I don't try to get into a debate.
However,
>> try to fall in love with a Muslim man.
Don't try to what? Fall in love with a
Muslim man.
Yeah, I'm not interested.
I know you're not, but you hang around
with enough Muslim men and try to
influence them,
and then
Satan comes in as the third to tempt you
and get you to weaken
Sister, why are you torturing me with
your microphone and the sound in the
background?
I'm sorry, that's my son.
Okay, sorry. Your son is not torturing
me cuz I keep hearing tick tick. Sorry.
No, it's okay. It's not your fault. So,
then that's good. Then you're married
then, right?
I am not, Sam. Okay, well, I didn't I
didn't mean I didn't mean to be per-
personal. What I'm trying to get at I'm
trying to protect you.
>> Yeah. God bless you and your child,
preserve you, and fill you with What I'm
saying now that I know you're not
married,
be careful, young woman,
because you may think you're strong,
then you will fall. 1 Corinthians 10
verse 12.
Right?
You do not know the power of Satan and
the weakness of your flesh. You're not
interested, but a Muslim man, especially
if you're in the military, suave, look
good-looking looks like he's got
everything in order, and the more you
interact with cuz you think you're
evangelizing him, and then you fall in
love with them.
I understand. Stay away from witnessing
to Muslim men. That's not your business.
Guard your heart. Guard your body. Be an
example for your son.
Focus on learning your faith, growing in
your faith, and go and read the
articles. Keep reading them. When you're
strong in your faith, then you may want
to read a Quran.
But you're going to have to teach your
son so he doesn't succumb to deception
of Islam.
And then you can ask questions when you
deal with Muslim women.
Deal with Muslim women, not Muslim men.
Because Muslim men can marry Christian
women which is in the Quran.
Timmy, she's okay.
Be patient.
She's in the military.
She loves the Lord. She has a son.
All this and coughing over you when you
speak, she doesn't mean it, man. What's
wrong with you, Timmy? Timmy got to I'm
trying
See?
It's not me coughing. It's my son. I
know. I'm just Timmy. Timmy.
Let her cough. She can hear me, man. But
anything else I can help you with,
Catherine?
I know. It's It was just that. Like I
said, to me it's just
understanding my limits.
I just think that
I need guidance. I need wisdom.
So just having that kind of
being able to ask those questions, um,
or somebody that can actually lead me
cuz I'm I'm I'm isolated. I'm isolated
and I can't lie. I'm in California and
here like
>> too much detail. So you're saying
California he what?
Who's he?
No. I said in just being here, I don't
have, let's say, uh,
a place where I'm grounded or, um, where
I can
you know, continuously visit and and get
that guidance that I really need
especially within my faith. Are you
there because of your military?
Mhm.
So you're in military. So but you're not
from California, then. So, that but you
for how long?
I just have like about a year and a half
left.
>> All right.
Well, what you're going to have to do is
I don't know where you're what area
you're in, but I don't need to know and
people don't need to know. You're going
to have to be intentional with your free
time
to search out solid conservative
churches
and then be active, proactive in going
there with your son and get involved. I
know you have no one and it seems like
you're just there with him.
I don't know where you've what where
your family is, but that's not my
business, but you have to be proactive
when you do have time to go search it
out, get plugged in the community, get
involved, and learn because when you go
now, you said you're looking at Catholic
Church, you can't take the Eucharist
until you're chrismated and baptized.
So, you're going to go there and as as
an observer.
And if you're interested, you can even
then join OCIA classes. Say, "Look, I'm
interested in
becoming Catholic, so I want to now
start the process and OCIA, they have it
weekly
for catechumens, but you cannot take
Eucharist, you can observe, and then
you're going to learn about
the dogmas of the Catholic faith, but
you have to find a solid conservative
one
because there's a lot of priests that
are wolves in our midst that are
liberal.
Stay away from them.
Right?
>> How do you know how do you know which
ones are liberal, which ones are not,
and that's what I mean.
>> Those who will tell you, "There are many
paths to God, so Muslims are saved." Or
it's okay if you're homosexual,
you're going to know because they're
going to
justify
all sorts of abominations,
immoralities,
because they are not truly Christian
from heart and they don't believe in
what the Bible teaches or what the
church has historically taught. So, to
them it's just a job. They are wolves in
clergy clothing
because
if you ask them
does the church dogmatically
teach it's okay for gen transgenderism?
No.
Because the church's teaching on sexual
ethics
has been codified. It's sealed.
Two genders, male and female. That's it.
No sex until marriage and it's got to be
in the sacrament of marriage.
Sacramental. Male and female.
That's it.
That's how you're going to know.
Especially
if they tell you, "Well, the Catholic
Church recognizes that there are many
paths to God. You can be saved." That's
a lie, too. That's not what
Vatican II states. That's not what the
catechism states. What they do is they
take the statements out of context to
deceive people. That's what it's
teaching.
That's how you're going to know. Now,
you're better off
you're you'll be safer if you find, for
example,
and I say this because there are wolves
everywhere, but you have a higher
likelihood of finding
a more conservative base if you look for
the Eastern Catholic rites.
You have the Chaldean Catholic Church.
That would be Eastern.
You also have the Eastern Catholic
Church, right? Even traditional Latin
Mass. Are you Hispanic?
I speak both languages.
Go to a traditional Latin Mass. I think
you'll fall in love with it. Find it.
Okay.